en salle étrange disparition d'octobre
dernier gilhodez et anne sophie van
damme s'était mystérieusement évaporé
avec leurs chiens en forêt de
fontainebleau
stéphane magnier and gas burget quelque
part entre la gorge ou louer la gorge au
voleur à peine dissimulé sous des
branchages de corps décomposé ceux d'un
homme d'une femme
à leurs côtés un cadavre qui pourrait
être celui d'un chien
nous ne pouvons par l'état actuel de nos
constatations grande obtenu de du relief
particulièrement accidenté de la forêt
de fontainebleau et de la nuit qui tombe
très vite en hiver nous ne pourrons pas
à ce moment précis vous dire réellement
six ans c'est en début d'après midi que
des gardes chasse ont donné l' alerte
dans ce secteur difficile d'accès très
marécageux
mais déjà ratissés par les gendarmes des
sous-bois des grottes démarre passé au
peigne fin
lorsque le 31 octobre dernier deux
jeunes promeneurs disparaissent anne
sophie van damme et gino des 25 ans
évanoui dans la nature avec leur chien
très vite les hypothèses selon
lesquelles le couple se serait égaré
aurait fait une mauvaise chute sont
abandonnés à plusieurs reprises les
militaires reviennent battu toujours
vaines jusqu'à aujourd'hui car il
pourrait bien cette fois s'agir des deux
jeunes promeneurs
les corps qui n'était pas enterrée se
trouvait en effet tout près du parking
où la voiture des fiancés a été retrouvé
le 1er novembre
fermée à clé vide l'enquète repart donc
tout repose maintenant sur le top 6
attendu pour cette nuit ou demain
le procès d'action directe avec une
séance très pénible aujourd'hui après
l'expulsion et les incidents d'hier une
séance cette fois où les quatre inculpés
les quatre dirigeants historiques du
mouvement terroriste ont quitté la salle
auparavant joëlle aubron
l'une des deux femmes avait lu un
discours emphatique et fumeux qui était
sans doute une forme d'aveu compte rendu
d'audience dominique verdeilhan
chronique d'une mort annoncée ainsi
joëlle aubron est l intitulé sans rire
un texte fastidieux de 27 pages pour
justifier l'assassinât de georges besse
la mort de georges besse déclare-t-elle
a été souhaitée espéré par la conscience
ouvrière
durant plus d'une heure dix actions
directes ainsi tenté de faire le procès
de l'ancien pdg de renault et ce sous le
regard abasourdi effondré de bananes
baisse et de ses enfants
bien sûr c'est très difficile bien sûr
c'est très douloureux mais en même temps
je savais bien qu'il fallait pour vivre
là c'est probablement la dernière
épreuve que j'aurais à subir après la
première et la plus cruelle qui était
celle de la mort de mon mari
alors il faut y passer pour louisa
vélique n'est pas une revanche
onze ans c'est vrai c'est vrai ce n'est
pas une vengeance mais comme je lé
d'hier nous avons des enfants et moi des
comptes à demander à des gens qui ont
tué froidement mon mari et c'est pour ça
que la justice fonctionne dans notre
démocratie
c'est donc une chose capitale non
seulement pour nous et au delà nous pour
la façon de vivre librement dans un pays
comme la france
après ce véritable rituel à chaque
procès d'action directe
les quatre accusés ont préféré quitter
la salle refusant d'entendre les
témoignages des policiers et experts
venus dresser la longue liste des
indices matériels à charge ainsi le
véritable procès aura donc commencer cet
après midi en l'absence les inculpés
urgence médicale en question avec deux
décisions de justice qui pose un
problème
première affaire c'est à evreux ou deux
médecins sont inculpés il ne s'était pas
rendu au chevet d'un enfant asthmatique
malgré l'appel des parents l'enfant
était mort dans la soirée
deuxième affaire à rennes elle est d'une
tout autre nature vous allez le voir
l'association sos médecins de la ville a
été condamné par le tribunal condamné à
retirer les gyrophares et les sigles de
ses voitures et dans plusieurs autres
villes sos médecin fait l'objet de
poursuites similaires car cette
organisation sos médecins abusent peut
être parfois de sa position alors droits
et devoirs de ces médecins d'urgence
jean daniel flaysakier
les gyrophares utilisé sans autorisation
des distribution d'autocollants de carte
de visite avec numéro d'appel la justice
n'a pas apprécié les méthodes
publicitaires de l'association sos
médecins de rennes il faut dire que
l'urgence est un sujet chaud en france
hormis les rapports difficiles entre
pompiers et samu il y à la querelle
entre les généralistes et les
associations de médecins qui ne font que
les urgences les premiers estiment que
trop souvent les secondes détournent
leur clientèle première visée
l'association sos médecins présente dans
45 villes portes de 500 médecins
on lui reproche des méthodes
commerciales pas toujours compatible
avec les règles de bonne conduite propre
à l'exercice médical ce qu'on appelle le
code de déontologie
vous savez sos médecins est devenu un
fait de société
ok ça fait 23 ans que nous existons
c'est nous avons une mission de fonction
publique
donc quand des gens font des recueils
utile de numéro de téléphone
eh ben sos médecins yeah parce que nous
avons cette notoriété
je crois qu'il faut se rappeler que la
médecine n'est pas un commerce est tout
à fait normal par exemple qu'une
entreprise de quincaillerie ou une
plomberie vente et même 20 avec un peu
d'hyperboles ces produits car il s'agit
de choses que l'on vend le médecin a en
face de lui une personne l'urgence n'est
pas une spécialité médicale reconnue
mais elle est là pour de nombreux
médecins une grande importance
économique
c'est sans doute ce qui fait aujourd'hui
que la querelle soirées animées
nouvelles révélations à propos du combat
aérien entre les avions américains et
libyens la semaine dernière les choses
n'étaient sans doute pas aussi simples
que l'on vit des américains
immédiatement après avoir abattu les
deux mig libyen les pilotes d'américains
ont sans doute tiré un petit peu vite
il s'agirait en fait d'une bavure le
pentagone commence à le reconnaître
didier epelbaum premières révélations
sur la procédure de mise en alerte des f
14 à l'heure h - 2 minutes 45 secondes
les chasseurs sont à 60 kilomètres des
mig libyen
l'opération est commandée en personne
par le contre amiral david morris il
transmet ses ordres depuis le
porte-avions kennedy par l'intermédiaire
d'un avion de liaison dont le nom de
code est close out écoutez
alerte jaune très attirés cela signifie
que les avions n'ont plus besoin
d'autorisation pour lancer leurs
missiles mais ils n'ont pas les ordres
de faire feu à volonté
deuxième révélation à 21 kilomètres des
mig pas de nouvelles instructions c'est
le pilote qui appelle le contre-amiral
même moment le copilote lens foxman
encode missile tiré 10 heures s'exclame
aussitôt le pilote mon dieu nouveau tiré
nouvel échec
apparemment le pilote a été surpris les
pilotes américains affirment ne pas
comprendre pourquoi les missiles ont été
tirés de si loin
troisième révélation à 8 km le leader
constate que l'inde et miga armés l'un
de ces missiles le second avion
américain ouvre le feu et abat un mig
l'autre avion libyen sera détruit par un
missile infrarouge selon un spécialiste
américain il semble avoir été abattus
alors qu'ils prenaient la fuite
demain fin de la conférence de paris sur
les armes chimiques les 140 pays qui
participent tentent en ce moment de
mettre au point une déclaration finale
une déclaration qui condamnerait
définitivement les armes chimiques
mais bien sûr tout le monde n'est pas
d'accord et la rédaction du texte traîne
un peu
georges bortoli à l'unesco un comité de
rédaction présidée par le ministre
falloir des les affaires étrangères va
travailler tard cette nuit tard parce
qu'il s'agit de mettre au point la
déclaration condamnant solennellement le
recours à l'armé chimique et que ce
n'est pas facile
alors vous me direz pas facile pourquoi
qui peut refuser de condamner l'armée
chimiques
rassurez vous personne simplement il ya
toujours la même objection de la part
des pays pauvres qui disent vous nous
demandez de renoncer à un recours
éventuel à quelques stocks d'armes
chimiques alors que vous avez de tout
autre moyen les pays riches et que vous
avez notamment la bombe atomique
donc on va où va condamner l'armé
chimique mais il faudra que d'une façon
ou de l'autre la déclaration finale
fasse référence à une notion plus
générale du désarmement plus générale
c'est à dire incluant l'armé nucléaire
la conférence de paris est suivi de très
près à stockholm car là bas en suède il
ya un organisme indépendant qui observe
tout ce qui se passe dans le monde au
sujet de ses armes chimiques
comment agnès poirier reportage le livre
de référence le voici celle suprieur
book
tous les experts le connaissent et
l'utilisent c'est ici aussi pris à
l'institut international de recherche
pour la paix de stockholm qui les mises
au point tous les ans 50 chercheurs y
travaillent en toute indépendance sa
dette des guerres et turcs
tous les jours elle compulse journaux et
publications du monde entier dans le
sipri year book elle établit les
dépenses militaires de chaque pays
agnès courade est la seule française son
travail tenir à jour une banque de
données extrêmement détaillées sur tout
ce qui concerne les ventes d'armes dans
le monde mais sipri est un institut
unique pour beaucoup de raisons mais la
principale c'est qu'elle regroupe des
chercheurs de différents pays des
différents systèmes politiques
nous avons des américains les allemands
des suédois des soviétiques ont turc un
indien et nous avons régulièrement des
visites de chercheurs de l'étranger nous
n'avons pas d'idéologie
nous avons un devoir qui est de
rechercher soigneusement d'après les
sources publiques accessibles à tous
tout ce qui concerne la sécurité
internationale des affaires militaires
le contrôle de l'armement et ensuite
nous le publions ici aussi pris on
s'intéresse de très près à la conférence
de paris sur les armes chimiques
johan van dyne experts dans ce domaine
on n'attend pas de miracle au moins
souligné t-il de plus en plus de gens
sont conscients du problème
je pense que nous sommes arrivés à un
point critique
il est absolument nécessaire de faire un
gros effort pour préparer un accord afin
que dans l'avenir on puisse freiner un
possible développement des armes
chimiques
si ça n'arrive pas maintenant je pense
qu'il faudra attendre longtemps
une nouvelle occasion car ici on
travaille sur l'armement mais aussi sur
les tentatives de paix nulle part
ailleurs un tel institut n'aurait pu
voir le jour
la suède n'a pas connu de guerre depuis
170 ans la ferté chine et elle commence
à prendre de plus en plus d'importance
lorsque pechiney a racheté une société
américaine des initiés mis au courant
ont ramassé un pactole
en rachetant avant tout le monde alors
qu'ils étaient ses initiés c'est toute
la question
on parle de personnes proches du pouvoir
actuel les autorités de la bourse à
paris et à new york enquête nous allons
y revenir
puis s'assied vous avez obtenu des
informations aujourd'hui sur ce sujet
brûlant et notamment sur une filière
suisse on a on a essayé on a tous essayé
au service économique en tout cas ce que
l'on peut dire c'est que les regards se
tournent en effet vers le pays qui
abrite le plus grand nombre d'organismes
privés de gestion financière en europe
la suisse à genève
plusieurs noms circulent des noms de
personnalités très connues à paris que
ray acheter à partir de la suisse des
actions américaines clients de la banque
de chine et annonça grande opération
achats effectués grâce à un bon tuyau
obtenu à paris ou à new york
à genève on parle beaucoup du nid
restions une société qu'a réussi déjà
quelques jolis coups de bourse à paris
et dont le dossier a été transmis en
1983 au parquet par la cob française
pour justement une affaire d'initiés
l'information est toujours en cours à la
question avez vous acheté des actions
criante pour ceux dont on cite les noms
le président du nigérian de son bureau
de genève m'a répondu aucun commentaire
c'est une affaire politique
je le cite à berne auprès des autorités
fédérales j'ai appris que les américains
avaient demandé aux suisses d'aller voir
dans leurs coffres forts ce qui s'était
passé au sujet de la sphère pechiney
triangle on dit que la france va faire
la même chose dans les jours qui
viennent les amériques
à la suite de leur enquête ont fait
bloquer les comptes dans quatre banques
suisses et dans plusieurs organismes de
gestion on refuse pour le moment
d'indiquer leur nom on verra si les deux
gendarmes de la bourse le français comme
des américains est ce ici irons jusqu'au
bout mais en tout cas comme dirait l'ami
[ __ ]
ça pourrait bardet merci philippe
effectivement le gendarme dans la sphère
à paris c'est la commission des
opérations de bourse la cob et à new
york c'est la sc un organisme identique
mais beaucoup plus sévère vous allez le
voir alors comment fonctionnent ces deux
organismes enquête paris new york car
cheval paul nahon attention ici
l'anonymat et le secret sont de rigueur
car certains dossiers examinés par la
cob la commission des opérations de
bourse sont explosifs
depuis sa création en 1967 la cob en
effet notamment pour mission de
surveiller les marchés financiers et
donc de traquer les manipulations de
cours
les violations des règles dopé à et puis
ce que l'on appelle les délits d'initiés
dans la sphère pechiney trail en gaule
par exemple le service de l'inspection
dirigée par le juge michaud qui occupe
l'un de ces bureaux s'emploie rechercher
ceux qui ont lâché certaines
informations privilégiées sur l'accord
passé entre les deux entreprises et ceux
qui les ont utilisées pour réaliser de
confortables plus-values en bourse juste
avant l'opération
c'est ensuite à la commission proprement
dite qui se réunit dans cette salle et
qui est composée de cinq membres dont le
président nommés par le chef de l'état
de décider de saisir ou non les
tribunaux les coupables de délits
d'initiés encourt une amende de 6000 à 5
millions de francs et une peine de
prison de 2 à 5 ans mais les transferts
au parc et restera quatre ou cinq chaque
année seulement sur une centaine
d'affaires les autorités de contrôle
exerce un pouvoir moral
ils affirment des principes ils n'ont
pas l'autorité pour les faire respecter
il ne dispose pas de façon générale de
pouvoir de sanction leur permettant
directement de mettre en oeuvre les
règles qu'ils énoncent les pouvoirs de
la cob devrait être un jour ou l'autre
renforcer sur la voie de l'exemple
américain
c'est dans ce building de new york près
de wall street que se tient la
redoutable commission des opérations en
bourse américaine cette commission a été
créée après le krach de wall street en
1929 pour surveiller les abus et les
conflits d'intérêts qui ont provoqué le
premier effondrement de la bourse
américaine son mandat est essentielle la
protection du petit porteur
les responsables de cet organisme sont
nommés en partie par la maison blanche
le congrès et le gouvernement américain
elle a des pouvoirs très étendus
il faut dit aussi que le simple mention
du nom le commission américaine c'est
trembler les professionnels américains
elle a des pouvoirs d'emprisonnement
effectivement ils allaient pouvoir
d'emprisonnement mais qui sont rarement
utilisées qu'à une simple censure de la
commission américaine est largement
suffisant pour discréditer avis
n'importe quelle fille ou individus et
ce sont les américains qui ont lancé l'
enquête sur la sphère pechiney ils vont
même jusqu en suisse pour chercher les
coupables
un mot de la politique avec la
préparation des municipales à grenoble 1
notables socialistes se rallie à la
liste du maire rpr de grenoble guînes
vaches rejoint en effet alain carignon
et puis municipale toujours une nouvelle
rencontre pc ps c'était place du colonel
fabien cet après midi pour l'instant les
deux parties ne sont pas encore parvenus
à se mettre d'accord les communistes et
les socialistes régleront la sphère
jeudi prochain ce jour là pierre mauroy
georges marchais se retrouveront la
catastrophe du doyen des midland airways
l'enquète continue un élément nouveau
aujourd'hui l'un des moteurs du boeing
avait été inexplicablement coupé avant
la chute de l'appareil lorsque l'autre
moteur a pris feu
les pilotes n'ont donc rien pu faire en
angleterre pour une auge ex 48 heures
après la catastrophe de key west
les enquêteurs sont toujours à pied
d'oeuvre autour du boeing des milandes
0,16
on sait désormais avec certitude que le
moteur droit a bien été coupée
aucune trace d'un incendie n'a été
retrouvée sur ce réacteur
si l'on ne connaît pas la cause de cette
coupure en revanche on n'est pas loin de
penser qu'elle aurait pu avoir lieu non
pas quelques secondes avant l'accident
mais entre londres et belle femme hec et
l'insead est en position de pousser zéro
c'est à dire de moteur coupé nous vivons
l'instant parler d'erreur de pilotage
mais on reste également très prudent
du côté de la snecma il y a semble-t-il
actuellement une certitude c'est qu'il y
a effectivement lieu
problème initialement en une heure son
hôte sur un moteur que s'est-il passé
ensuite je n'ai pas d'éléments pour
pouvoir porter un jugement
par contre ce que tout le monde sait
c'est qu'il y a une probabilité
infinitésimale qu'il y ait simultanément
panneaux sur ses deux moteurs et aussi
ce qu'il faut dire c'est que ce qui fait
la force
une réputation et le succès de ce moteur
cfm56 c'est précisément ses performances
et sa fiabilité
les moteurs vont être acheminées dans
les prochaines heures dans des
laboratoires afin d'être examiné deux
éléments importants restent à étudier la
boîte noire et le témoignage du pilote
rescapé
l incendie à paris aurait au mur dans un
entrepôt de tissu c'est dans le centre
de paris dans le 2ème arrondissement
heureusement il n'y a aucune victime
tout le monde a pu être évacués à temps
il y avait beaucoup beaucoup de fumée
vous le voyez mais c'est tout pas de
victime à l'origine sans doute un court
circuit
en allemagne une infirmière est accusé
d'être l'une des plus grandes criminel
de l'histoire l'ange de la mort c'est
ainsi que la surnomment ses collègues de
l'hôpital
cette jeune infirmière aurait tué
dix-sept patients de l'hôpital soit
disant pour les aider à mourir
enquête en allemagne philippe rochot une
femme solide et décidé à 30 ans michael
à roeser aurait 17 morts sur la
conscience sans mobile apparent des
personnes âgées assassiné par piqûre
après une opération
jusqu'à ce jour de septembre 85 où elle
est surprise par un infirmier
michael schroeder ne plaident pourtant
pas coupable elle veut dit-elle profiter
de ce procès pour rectifier certaines
choses
c'est à l'hôpital saint-pierre de
wuppertal qu'elle travaillait et c'est
avec un paralysant cardiaque qu'elle
tuer froidement ces malades
j'ai voulu les soulager de leurs
souffrances at elle dit à la police au
moment de son arrestation
d'emblée elle a reconnu avoir tué six
malades puis enquête et autopsies ont
permis de voir que onze autres personnes
dans son service était morte de la même
façon la défense a choisi de la
présenter comme une militante de
l'euthanasie
nouvelle incertitude en afghanistan les
soviétiques laisse encore planer le
doute à propos du retrait de l'armée
rouge
c'est en principe avant le 15 février
mais le doute est entretenu par monsieur
varone sauf qu'ils négociaient jusqu'à
hier avec les moudjahidine voyons
maintenant d'autres faits marquants de
l'actualité de ce mardi
en bref en images michel mompontet 450
militaires cubains qui regagne la havane
voici la première application concrète
du traité de paix en afrique australe
signé par l'afrique du sud l'angola et
cuba
le 22 décembre dernier à new york ces
militaires cubains font partie du
contingent de 50 mille hommes qui durant
13 ans a buté aux côtés de l'angola
marxiste contre l'afrique du sud et ses
alliés fidel castro avait dit il ya deux
ans à peine
nous ne partirons en angola qu'une fois
l'apartheid aboli
malgré cet échec flagrant ces soldats
sont attendus à la havane comme des
héros l'onu aura bien du mal avec
seulement 70 hommes à superviser un tel
départ
au liban le nombre des morts lors des
combats entre milices et chiites rivales
d'amal et du hezbollah ne cesse de
s'accroître
dans la seule journée d'aujourd'hui au
moins 25 nouvelles victimes et miliciens
d'amal aurait ce soir repris au
hezbollah les villages que ceux ci leur
avaient ravi lors de l'offensive
surprise de dimanche soir en trois jours
il ya déjà eu 89 morts
les ticos pardon l'épiscopat français
pour la première fois prend
officiellement position sur la
prévention du sida alors ce qui frappe
dans le document publié c'est que il s'y
manifeste une nouvelle tolérance
l'épiscopat ne condamne plus
explicitement la publicité et l' usage
des préservatifs alors est-ce un
tournant dans l'attitude de l'église
vis-à-vis de la sexualité avec nous le
père jean michel di falco qui est porte
parole de l'épiscopat bonsoir mon père
alors l'église tolère tel maintenant oui
ou non l'utilisation des préservatifs
dans la perspective bien sûr de la
prévention du sida
je crois qu'à bordeaux le texte des
évêques dans ce oui ou non c'est le
réduire je crois je voudrais dire
d'abord que ce n'est pas aux évêques de
justifier une campagne sanitaire
ils ne sont pas des médecins donc le miz
la santé intervient lui au niveau
sanitaire
les évêques interviennent à un niveau
éthique mais on remarque quand même dans
ce document que vous ne condamnez plus
quand même comme l'ont fait récemment
dont seigneur de courtrai ou même
monseigneur lustiger
d'une part les citations que vous
reprenez un concernant ces les deux
cardinaux sont des interventions qui ont
un fragment terre qui ont pu être faites
ici et là l'occasion de l'intervention
dans une radio en ce qui concerne le
cardinal lustiger je vous rappelle que
le 1er décembre 88 lors d'une émission
de télévision il avait dit lui même si
vous êtes malade ne donnait pas la mort
utiliser les moyens qu'on vous propose
bon c'est vrai mais tout de même il
semble que le document que vous proposez
maintenant représente quand même un
changement moi je voudrais vous demander
est ce que ce changement traduit aussi
une chambre un changement d'optique de
l'église sur toute la sexualité non je
crois qu'on voulait absolument me
ramener réduire ce texte à cette
question je pense qu'il est beaucoup
plus large
d'une part il aborde la relation aux
malades
l'accueil indispensable qui doit être
fait tel est l'exemple du christ aux
malades pas de ségrégation crois que
c'est très important qu'on se savait
dire concrètement justement pas
d'exclusion des malades pas de
ségrégation ça veut dire quoi dans la
vienne tout simplement car quand on
constate l'évolution de la maladie au
jour
il est certain qu'ils poussent à peut
provoquer des réflexes de peur des
réflexes de rejet il est normal que les
évêques rappellent et tout
particulièrement aux chrétiens et aux
catholiques qu' il ya une attitude
cohérente avec l'évangile est cohérente
avec le latitude même du christ c'est à
dire pas de rejet par rapport aux
malades et que tout soit fait pour que
il on fasse naître chez eux
l'espérance qui peut les aider à vivre
mieux cette maladie la preuve d'ailleurs
de l'église n'a encore donne la donne
dans la création de lieux d'accueil que
ce soit paris que ce soit à lyon et bien
avant à new york par exemple mère teresa
dernière question vers jean michel di
falco
le professeur go qui a été chargé par le
gouvernement d'un rapport sur le sida
est en train de le publier justement ces
jours ci il parle d'une nullité totale
de la politique de santé publique dans
ce domaine est ce que l'église a une
opinion proches
écoutez je l' ai dit tout à l'heure ce
n'est pas d'une aubaine les évêques
d'intervenir au niveau médical je pense
que là ils interviennent au niveau qui
est le leur camp l'église parle elle
s'inspire de la parole du christ qui la
fait vivre sa mission aujourd'hui c'est
de rappeler ses idéaux que sont la
dignité de l'amour humain la fidélité et
la chasteté
il n'appartient pas à l'église de porter
un jugement sur les conditions
sanitaires
oui effectivement ce sont des sujets
très vaste nous aurons certainement
l'occasion d'y revenir merci mon père
sans transition le sport maintenant avec
tout d'abord un résultat de ce qui le
somment géant de kirchberg a été gagné
par l'autrichien ni riches
c'est lui qui à arbitrer le duel entre
les deux favoris le suisse zurbriggen et
l'italien tombe à respectivement
deuxième et troisième de cette épreuve
de coupe du monde
en ce moment d'ailleurs les autrichiens
domine largement la coupe du monde et
les français en revanche font pâle
figure en revanche sur les mers ça va
beaucoup mieux les français passent d'un
défi à l'autre après olivier de
kersauson parti pour le tour du monde
sans escale
voici maintenant philippe monnet il veut
lui battre le record de la traversée new
york san francisco par le cap horn
c'est un record vieux de plus d'un
siècle jean ma mère new york sous la
neige et un froid approchant les -15 2
et comme à l'époque des grands clippers
ses voisins de quai philippe monnet n'a
pas hésité pourtant à larguer les
amarres pour s'attaquer aux plus vieux
record de voile un dernier baiser à sa
fiancée avant de partir seul pour un peu
moins de 89 jours en cas de réussite
dans son défi partir seul sur un
trimaran c'est une première difficulté
boucler le budget en est une deuxième et
ce ne sera malheureusement pas la
dernière poche au passé c'est après
l'équateur enfin là c'est un point chaud
mais agréable très le point chaud en
basse et c'est le froid le froid du horn
et les vents qui sont très mauvais et la
mer qui est monstrueuse le revoir à new
york avant l' isolement total et la
route parsemée de danger le premier
affronter les grosses vagues du courant
chaud du golf stream et de ses vents
contraires puis les côtes d'afrique
avant et après le cap horn
philippe monnet a déjà effectué un tour
du monde sans escale à la poursuite
d'alain colas cette fois sur sa
libellule de 18 mètres il s'attaque à
flying cloud 1 82 68 mètres de long
c'était il est vrai il y à déjà 124 ans
camille claudel qui était une femme
sculpteur comme vous le savez triomphe à
l'écran sous les traits d'isabelle
adjani
vous le savez aussi mais camille claudel
triomphe également dans une galerie
parisienne du faubourg saint-honoré qui
expose ses oeuvres
car ces oeuvres ont longtemps été
ignorée mais elles sont maintenant
unanimement loué notamment la statue
baptisée percée et la gorgone une statue
qui fait bien des envieux à travers le
monde notamment du côté du japon
personne n'avait l'assurance qu'elle
resterait dans le patrimoine français
et bien voici les révélations de georges
bégoux sur son avenir
il n'ya un mois ou découvriez les
premières images du chef-d'oeuvre de
marbre de camille claudel percée et la
gorgone fraîchement achetée à washington
par la galerie odermatt cazaux à ce
moment là philippe cazaux nous exprimer
sa préférence vendre la sculpture à un
mécène français
un grand souhait que j'ai la faire
acheter peut-être par le mécénat
français par un grand chef d'entreprise
qui pourrait à titre de mécénat l'offrir
par exemple au musée rodin pourquoi pas
elle et elle aurait tout à fait sa place
et et ces deux là en fait qu'elle doit
être
si j'étais vsn ça me coûterait très cher
fonds qui serait ça vous coûte rsa vous
coûterait très cher oui ça vous
coûterait autour de 2 8 millions de
francs les japonais se précipitaient
déjà quand cet amateur d'art spectateur
attentif d'antenne 2 et qui n'a pas
l'oeil [ __ ] est venu tourner autour de
percer il a ouvert le chéquier des
assurances générales de france souvent
dans le mécénat d'entreprise c'est pour
l'entreprise
on investit tandis que là nous allons
mettre cette statue dans notre grand
rôle rue de richelieu à 50 mètres de la
bibliothèque nationale
elle serait toujours à la disposition du
public oui mais les hfc pas seulement
richelieu c'est aussi la france entière
lorsqu'elle va tourner elle tournera
dans nos sept délégations régionales
vous savez que le vendeur imaginer que
peut-être un jour elle serait au musée
rodin de keller face et pour un jour pas
l'exclure mais en attendant nous avons
envie de la voir chez nous et de la
montrer chez nous à tout le monde
voilà et moi je sais très bien camille
claudel avec le che qui d'antenne 2 bien
sûr fin de ce journal tout de suite la
météo ce sera sophie davant la dernière
édition
tout à l'heure après 23 heures henri
sannier juste après sarah labarre
présentée par roger zabel zabel que vous
retrouverez demain matin pour télé matin
à 6h45 et d'ailleurs dans télématin l'
invité des 4 vérités de gérard morin ce
sera jean claude gaudin bonsoir à demain
à